all right so today I'm going to be
talking about the Lagrangian now we've
talked about Lagrange multipliers this
is a highly related concept in fact it's
not really teaching anything new this is
just repackaging stuff that we already
know so to remind you of the set up this
is going to be a constrained
optimization problem set up so we'll
have some kind of multivariable function
f of X Y and the one I have pictured
here is let's see it's x squared times e
to the Y times y so what what I have
shown here is a contour line for this
function so that is we say what happens
if we set this equal to some constant
and we ask about all values of x and y
such that this holds such that this
function outputs that constant and if I
choose a different constant and that
contour line could look a little bit
different it's kind of nice that it has
similar shapes so that's that's the
function and we're trying to maximize it
the goal is to maximize this guy and of
course it's not just that the reason we
call it a constrained optimization
problem is because there's some kind of
constraint some kind of other function G
of X Y in this case x squared plus y
squared and we want to say that this has
to equal some specific amount in this
case I'm going to set it equal to 4 so
we say you can't look at any X Y to
maximize this function you're limited to
the values of x and y that satisfied
this property and I talked about this in
the last couple videos and kind of the
cool thing that we found was that you
look through the various different
contour lines of f and the maximum will
be achieved when that contour line is
just perfectly parallel to this contour
of G and you know a pretty classic
example for what you what these sorts of
things could mean or how it's used in
practice is if this was say a revenue
function for some kind of company and
kind of modeling your revenues based on
different choices you could make running
that company and the constraint that
you'd have would be lets say a budget so
I'm just going to go ahead and write
budget or B for budget here so you're
trying to maximize revenues and then you
you have some sort of dollar limit for
what you're willing to spend and these
of course are just kind of made-up
functions you'd never have a budget that
looks like a circle and this kind of
random configuration for your revenue
but in principle you know what I mean
right
so the way that we took advantage of
this tangency property and I think this
is pretty clever let me just kind of
redraw it over here you're looking at
the point where the two functions are
just tangent to each other is that the
gradient the gradient vector for the
thing we're maximizing which in this
case is R is going to be parallel or
proportional to the gradient vector of
the constraint which in this case is B
is going to be proportional to the
gradient of the constraint and what this
means is that if we were going to solve
a set of equations what you set up is
you compute that gradient of r and it
will involve you know two different
partial derivatives and you set it equal
not to the gradient of B because it's
not necessarily equal to the gradient of
B but it's proportional with some kind
of proportionality constant lambda now
let me was kind of a squirrelly lambda
lambda now that one's doesn't look good
either does it
y or lambda is so hard to draw all right
that looks fine so the gradient of the
revenue is proportional to the gradient
of the budget and we did a couple
examples of solving this kind of thing
this gives you two separate equations
from the two partial derivatives and
then you use this right here this budget
constraint as your third equation and
the Lagrangian the point of this video
this lagrangian function is basically
just a way to package up this equation
along with this equation into a single
entity so it's not really adding new
information and if you're solving things
by hand it doesn't really do anything
for you
but what makes it nice is that it's
something easier to hand a computer and
I'll show you what I mean so I'm going
to define the lagrangian itself which we
write with this kind of funky looking
script l and it's a function with the
same inputs that your revenue function
or the thing that you're maximizing has
along with lambda along with that
Lagrange multiplier and the way that we
define it and I'm going to need some
extra room so I'm going to say it's
equal to and kind of define it down here
the revenue function or whatever it is
that you're maximizing the function that
you're maximizing minus lambda that
Lagrange multiplier so that's just
another input to this new function that
we're defining multiplied by the
constraint function and this
be evaluated at XY minus whatever that
constraint value is in this case I put
in 4 so you'd write minus 4 if we wanted
to be more general maybe we would write
you know be 4 whatever your budget is so
over here you're subtracting off little
B so this here is a new multi variable
function right it's something where you
could input X Y and lambda and just kind
of plug it all in and you'd get some
kind of value and remember B in this
case is a is a constant so I'll go ahead
and write that that this right here is
not considered a variable this is just
some constant your variables are X Y and
lambda and this would seem like a
totally weird and random thing to do if
you just saw it out of context or if it
was unmotivated but what's kind of neat
and we'll go ahead and work through this
right now is that when you take this is
that when you take the gradient of this
function called the Lagrangian and you
set it equal to zero that's going to
encapsulate all three equations that you
need and I'll show you what I mean by
that so let's let's just remember the
gradient of L that that's a vector it's
got three different components since L
has three different inputs you're going
to have the partial derivative of L with
respect to X you're going to have the
partial derivative of L with respect to
Y and then finally the partial
derivative of L with respect to lambda
our Lagrange multiplier which we're
considering an input to this function
and remember whenever we write that a
vector equals zero really we mean the
zero vector often you'll see it in bold
if it's in a textbook but what we're
really saying is we set those three
different functions the three different
partial derivatives all equal to zero so
this is just a nice like closed form
compact way of saying that all of its
partial derivative is equal to zero now
let's go ahead and think about what
those partial derivatives actually are
so this first one the partial with
respect to X partial derivative of the
Lagrangian with respect to X it's kind
of fun you know you have all these curly
symbols the curly D the curly L it makes
it look like you're doing some truly
advanced math but really it's just kind
of
artificial fanciness right but anyway so
we take the partial derivative with
respect to X and what that equals is
well it's whatever the partial
derivative of R with respect to X is
minus and then lambda from X's
perspective at lambda just looks like a
constant so it's going to be lambda and
then this inside the parentheses the
partial derivative of that with respect
to X well it's going to be whatever the
partial derivative of B is with respect
to X but subtracting off that constant
that doesn't change the derivative so
this right here is the partial
derivative of lambda with respect to X
now if you set that equal to zero and I
know I've kind of run out of room on the
right here but if you set that equal to
zero that's the same as just saying that
the partial derivative of R with respect
to X equals lambda times the partial
derivative of B with respect to X and if
you think about what's going to happen
when you unfold this property that the
gradient of R is proportional to the
gradient of be written up here that's
just the first portion of this right if
we're setting the gradients equal then
the first component of that is to say
that the partial derivative of R with
respect to X is equal to lambda times
the partial derivative of V with respect
to X and then if you do this for y if we
take the partial derivative of this
Lagrangian function with respect to Y
it's very similar right it's going to be
well you just take the partial
derivative of R with respect to Y in
fact it all looks just identical
whatever R is you take as partial
derivative with respect to Y and then we
subtract off lambda looks like a
constant as far as Y is concerned and
then that's multiplied by well what's
the partial derivative of this this term
inside the parenthesis with respect to Y
well is the partial of B with respect to
Y and again again if you imagine setting
that equal to zero that's going to be
the same as setting this partial
derivative term equal to lambda times
this partial derivative term right you
kind of just bring one to the other side
so this second component of our
lagrangian equals zero equation is just
the second function that we've seen and
a lot of these exam
that we've been doing where you set one
of the gradient vectors proportional to
the other one
and the only real difference here from
stuff that we've seen already and even
then it's not that different is that
what happens when we take the partial
derivative of this Lagrangian with
respect to lambda with respect now we'll
go ahead and give it that kind of green
lambda color here well when we take that
partial derivative if we kind of look up
at the definition of the function R or
never has a lambda in it right it's
purely a function of x and y so that
looks just like a constant when we're
differentiating with respect to lambda
so that's just going to be zero when we
take its partial derivative and then
this next component B of XY minus B all
of that just looks like a constant as
far as lambda is concerned right there's
X's there's Y there's this constant B
but none of these things have lambdas in
them so when we take the partial
derivative with respect to lambda this
just looks like some big constant times
lambda itself that's what we're going to
get is I guess we're subtracting off
right let's go up here kind of writing a
minus sign we're subtracting off all the
stuff that was in those parentheses B of
X Y minus B that constant and this whole
thing if we set that whole thing equal
to 0 well that's pretty much the same as
setting B of X Y minus B equal to 0 and
that that's really just the same as
saying hey we're setting B of XY equal
to that little B right setting this
partial derivative of the Lagrangian
with respect to the Lagrange multiplier
equal to zero boils down to the
constraint right the third equation that
we need to solve so in that way
setting the gradient of this Lagrangian
function equal to zero is just a very
compact way of packaging three separate
equations that we need to solve the
constraint optimization problem and I'll
emphasize that in practice if you you
know if you actually see a function for
our for the thing that you're maximizing
and a function for the budget it's much
better I think to just directly think
about these parallel gradients and kind
of solve it from there
because if you construct the Lagrangian
and then compute its gradient all you're
really doing is repackaging it up only
to unpackage it again but the point of
this kind of the reason that this is a
very useful construct is that computers
often have really fast ways of solving
things like this things like the
gradient of some function equals zero
and the reason is because that's how you
solve unconstrained maximization
problems right this is very similar to
as if we just looked at this function l
out-of-context and were asked hey what
is its maximum value what are the
critical points that it has and you said
it's grading equal to zero so kind of
the whole point of this Lagrangian is
that it turns our constrained
optimization problem involving R and B
in this new made-up variable lambda into
an unconstrained of an optimization
problem where we're just setting the
gradient of some function equal to zero
so computers can often do that really
quickly so if you just hand the computer
this function it will be able to find
you an answer whereas you know it's
harder to say hey computer I want you to
think about when the gradients are
parallel and also consider this
constraint function as just kind of a a
cleaner way to package it all up so with
that I'll see you next video where I'm
going to talk about the significance of
this lambda term how it's not just a
ghost variable but it actually has a
pretty nice interpretation for a given
constraint problem